Penthouse and Stephen King
While to date Stephen King has managed to
sell about 350 million copies of his novels,
he started out with quite humble beginnings
as an author.
After graduating from the University of Maine
with a degree in English in 1970, Stephen
King couldn’t find work as a teacher at
first, so continued to work odd jobs, such
as at an industrial laundry service.
In 1971, he managed to get a high school teaching
job at Hampden Academy, but continued to pursue
his dream of becoming a professional writer
by working on novels on the side, as well
as selling some of his short stories to various
magazines, such as Cavalier, Ubris, Penthouse,
and Cosmopolitan.
His big break came not too long after he began
teaching, when Doubleday agreed to publish
Carrie in 1973 (ultimately published in 1974),
which was a bestseller and allowed him to
be able to quit teaching and devote himself
full time to writing.
He followed this up by immediately writing
Salem’s Lot during the summer of 1973 (published
in 1975), while living in a small summer home
in Maine where he’d moved to help take care
of his ailing mother, who was dying of uterine
cancer (which she ultimately lost her battle
with at the age of 59).
Despite this success as a full-time writer
(and taking up a position as a creative writing
teacher at the University of Maine in 1977),
King still occasionally would write short
stories to sell to magazines, including the
15 page short story, The Children of the Corn,
which was published in the March of 1977 edition
of Penthouse.
One year after Children of the Corn was published,
he bundled up many of the short stories he’d
written for the various magazines and put
them in a book of their own, Night Shift,
which would go on to win the Balrog Award
for Best Collection, as well as be nominated
for the World Fantasy Award and the Locus
Award.
It also spawned numerous film/TV/theater adaptations
of the stories in the compilation including
The Lawnmower Man, Graveyard Shift, Cat’s
Eye (which incidentally starred 10 year old
Drew Barrymore), The Mangler, and Sometimes
They Come Back.
Five years after Night Shift was published,
Children of the Corn was adapted into a low
budget short film called Disciples of the
Crow.
One year later, it was again adapted, this
time with a much bigger budget, to the movie
Children of the Corn, which Stephen King originally
wrote the screen play for, but his version
was thrown out due to having too much dialogue
and back-story.
Instead a much more violent/gory version with
more conventional narrative style was written
by George Goldsmith and used for the film.
Bonus Stephen King Facts:
Another famed short story by Stephen King,
The Ledge, was also originally published in
Penthouse Magazine, this one in the July 1976
edition.
As a testament to the fact that, as a writer,
you can never really tell what people will
end up liking, King actually threw the incomplete
Carrie in the trash, but the draft was rescued
by his wife who convinced him to finish it.
It soon earned him $400,000 ($1.7M today)
for the paperback rights alone and allowed
him to quit his day job, as mentioned above.
Stephen King allows any student film/theater
group to use his stories in their productions
for just $1 a story, called “The Dollar
Deal”.
In his early years as a professional writer,
Stephen King also wrote under the name Richard
Bachman.
This may seem a strange thing for an author
to do when they are first trying to build
their “brand”, but King had good reason,
“I did that because back in the early days
of my career there was a feeling in the publishing
business that one book a year was all the
public would accept, but I think that a number
of writers have disproved that by now.
… Ed McBain is another novelist who publishes
multiple books in some years and his original
name was Evan Hunter.
That’s the name he’s always published
under and he adopted the pen name of Ed McBain
for the same reason I adopted Richard Bachman
and that was that.
It made it possible for me to do two books
in one year.
I just did them under different names and
eventually the public got wise to this because
you can change your name, but you can’t
really disguise your style.”
King came up with the name “Richard Bachman”
off the cuff.
His publisher called and asked what name they
should put on the novel and King had a book
by Richard Stark on his desk, so used the
name “Richard” and he had music on in
the background by Bachman Turner Overdrive
(You Ain’t Seen Nothin’ Yet), so he told
them “Richard Bachman”.
The photo of “Richard Bachman”
The photo of Richard Bachman that appeared
in the books was of Richard Manuel, an insurance
agent of King’s literary agent, Kirby McCauley.
Before he went with the Bachman name, King
briefly considered publishing under Gus Pillsbury,
which was his maternal grandfather.
“Bachman’s” identity was discovered
Steve Brown, a bookstore Clerk, who became
convinced that Bachman and King were the same
person, despite all of King’s efforts to
hide the fact, including dedicating a book
to Bachman’s fictional wife, “Clauda Inez
Bachman”.
In order to route out the truth, Brown decided
to go to the Library of Congress and look
up publisher records to see if there were
any records connecting Bachman and King.
What he found there was a document that listed
King as the author of one of Bachman’s books.
Brown subsequently sent a copy of this to
King’s publishers and received a phone call
from King himself suggesting that Brown interview
King and then write an article about if for
publication.
This article was published in the Washington
Post.
King later sent out a press release stating
that Bachman had died of “cancer of the
pseudonym”.
Despite today being something of a cult classic,
the film Children of the Corn was not well
received in its day, garnering mostly negative
reviews from critics and even today has a
“Rotten” rating of 39% on Rotten Tomatoes.
It did, however, bring in about $14.5M vs.
a budget of only $800,000.
Unlike the movie, in the original short story,
neither Burt nor Vikki survive the ordeal.
Specifically, Vikki has her eyes cut out and
is murdered and “He Who Walks Behind the
Rows” kills Burt after Burt discovers Vikki’s
body.
When Stephen King was just two years old,
his father, who was a merchant seaman, went
to “buy a pack of cigarettes”, but never
came home, abandoning the family.
Another traumatic thing that happened to King
as a child, though he says today he has no
memory of the event, was watching his friend
get hit by a train.
When King came home after this, he didn’t
mention it, but seemed in shock and wouldn’t
talk.
Later, his mother learned that King’s friend
had been hit by a train and killed while playing
with King.
Stephen King briefly considered retiring in
2002.
This was largely due to being hit by a car
in 1999.
Bryan Smith, the driver of the car had been
distracted by his dog in his car and hit King,
who went flying approximately 14 ft.
From this, he suffered a collapsed right lung,
shattered bones in his leg that were so severe
the doctors strongly considered amputating
it, broken hip, and scalp lacerations.
Despite the severe injuries and five operations
over the course of the next couple weeks,
King resumed work almost immediately upon
being released from the hospital.
However, because of his injuries, sitting
became painful, which by 2002 prompted King
to announce that he would retire from writing.
However, he was soon back at it, though at
a much less breakneck pace than before.
As he states on his website, “I’m not
a kid of 25 anymore and I’m not a young
middle-aged man of 35…-I have grandchildren
and I have a lot of things to do besides writing
and that in and of itself is a wonderful thing
but writing is still a big, important part
of my life and of everyday.”
For prospective writers, King recommends reading
and writing for at least 4-6 hours per day,
every day, to become a good writer.
His personal quota every day is a minimum
of 2000 words before he’ll allow himself
to stop and do something else if he so chooses.